[Applause]
during the break we were chatting about
the office uh a show
uh so many of us absolutely loved and
and it ending what do you
think you're gonna miss the most about
going to work on that show
day in and day out is there one thing
you're gonna miss probably more than
anything else i'm gonna miss a lot
uh about going to work there probably
the 5 30 a.m call times yeah um
but no it's the people you know like it
just really was a second family for a
lot of us
and uh and there's so many
just the the friendships are so strong
and we just made each other laugh all
the time
um krazynski as you know
is one of the funniest people of all
time what's so great about a great
physical comic he does a lot of very
funny physical stuff that's what's so
surprising because jim his character on
the office is so
cool and collected but but when
krazynski cuts loose
he he's just a riot we had all these
little inside bits
on the set stupid little jokes um
like what was your favorite thing that
you would do with with john um
it's not highbrow stuff uh well well
they're you're in the right place
you should be relaxing would do uh
sometimes we would just snap into our
our impressions of of a rock
right how does that work so this is our
this is this is picture john and i doing
this together
this is my impression of a rock
[Laughter]
[Applause]
for for thousands of years you would
just do that
it's just millennia yeah for millions of
years and occasionally occasionally it
would be something like this
but we should try this we should be like
a little clump of rocks
yeah because this is how all right okay
ready
go
all right honey good that's i think
was the happiest rock well that's kind
of the mine had a lot of uh
issues and andy seems terrified right
i was thinking someone might throw me
into the ocean and i'd take thousands of
years to get back
that's exactly what i would worry about
our rocks were always very very happy i
don't know why
was there another bit you guys used to
oh this okay so we
did a uh we would do this bit of
a guy who is woken up
by and startled by his own fart
yeah and and and and the this is an
acting
technique that the uh shakespearean
actor is used back of course
and and the joke is is that your star
he's startled when when he's woken up so
he says like some crazy non-sequitur
so it would be like
where's my car
like i said not eyebrow stuff not high
brow stuff
you did warn us you did warn us all
right we have a clip here from the uh
hangover part three tell us what is
happening in this clip
uh set it up as they say in the lingo
okay if i am remembering correctly
this is the clip where chao
and i are are we have a little mission
impossible moment we're trying to break
into a house
is okay let's take a look this is where
you and chad were trying to break into a
house
okay i'm here now what
pull the cover off so you can see the
wires
done okay on three cut the gray wire
one two wait
i don't have a gray wire i have red
green and yellow that's weird
i have light gray medium gray and dark
gray
my bad i'm colorblind
part three opens thursday ed always an
honor and a pleasure